es la primera vez que una tripulación
llega a la estación espacial
internacional en una cápsula reutilizada
y tras emplear un propulsor que también
se usó en el pasado en guys
lasaña podría revolucionar el transporte
espacial al abaratar costos one es la
primera misión conjunta de la nasa la
agencia espacial europea y la agencia
japonesa del espacio de más de 20 años
sex cutis y es el tercer vuelo comercial
conjunto que realizan la nasa y space
extras las misiones demo 1 y 16 station
toma pesqué de francia jane kimber y
megan mcarthur de eeuu y akihiko hoshide
de japón recibieron la cálida bienvenida
de sus colegas 166 estamos muy
emocionados por ser parte de esta
histórica misión con las dos
tripulaciones de la cápsula dragón a
bordo primera vez que se reutiliza una
cápsula primera vez que se reutiliza un
propulsor es un logro tremendo de
nuestros compañeros de spacex así que
quiero felicitarlos y agradecer nada por
la misión crudo se estará durante seis
meses en el espacio realizando más de
200 experimentos en el espacio entonces
cuando estén en órbita
en principio no se siente gravedad pero
si hay un poquito muy poquito que se
nota como que te tira un poco es un lado
por eso sea microgravedad
de todas las cosas que se hacen en la
estación espacial todos los experimentos
biológicos o químicos de crecimiento de
cristales de formación de sólidos de
estructura de líquidos bajo
microgravedad son diría yo lo más
esencial porque es lo que lo que de
ninguna manera puede realizar en la
tierra los astronautas también tendrán
que actualizar el sistema de energía
solar de la estación y trabajarán en
estudios de chips de tejidos pequeños
modelos de órganos humanos